bonsoir et merci d'être en direct sur rt
france jean castex évoque une baisse
réelle de l'épidémie depuis dix jours et
ce cas c'est ce que vous constatez vous
dans les hôpitaux bien nous soignons ce
que l'on constate c'est que depuis six
mois on est sur un couteau c'est à dire
que pour nous la deuxième vague
elle a commencé en novembre et depuis
elle est restée haute
donc c'est un vrai souci il a le
discours de dix ans
oui on est content on se rapproche de 30
mille cas par jour
c'est un c'est mieux bah ouais certes
mais l'objectif fixé par le président
s'était samica par par jour lorsqu'on
est rentré dans la logique du
confinement en novembre à l'eau premier
ministre a donc confirmé que les
contraintes de déplacement en journée
serait levé à partir du 3 mai est ce que
vous considérez que c'est une sage
décision
après ce que vous venez molière en
france on est dans la demie milieu
c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu de d'avoir fait
confinement comme comme la première fois
où on aurait stoppé des nets comme la
première fois là on est dans un entre
deux où depuis novembre il ya des
mesures qui bloquent d'une partie la vie
économique sans avoir à trop d'impact
sur le milieu sanitaire et c'est ça qui
est quand même inquiétant donc en
particulier la la réouverture des
établissements scolaires sans mesures
adaptées
parce que c'est ce qui nous inquiète le
discours de monsieur castex et dire
soit on ouvre les établissements
scolaires souvent les fermes bas
non il y à un entre deux qui fait part
d'autres pays en particulier
m des purificateurs d'air dans chaque
classe dans chaque cantine pour limiter
la transmission
alors il n'y aurait pas des
sacrificateurs des rats a priori mais le
chef du gouvernement a annoncé que 400
mille tests salivaires seraient déployés
dans les écoles élémentaires la semaine
prochaine commande
aussi c'est ce qu'il a indiqué de 64
millions d'autos test pour les
personnels de l'éducation nationale puis
dès mi séance
est-ce que c'est développe des décisions
qui malgré tout vont dans le bon sens
non ce qu'il faut c'est bloqué et pour
bloquer vous mettez un purificateur
d'air dans une salle de classe
c'est un appareil qui vous quelques
centaines d'euros
c'est de l'air qui passe dans le milieu
chargé en ultra violet et qui purifie et
ça devrait le faire
le demande depuis la rentrée de
septembre
et ce n'est toujours pas fait il
faudrait généraliser les demies groupe
partout dans tous les niveaux de des
établissements scolaires et la sefee au
volontariat dans certains endroits ce
dans certaines tranches d'âge et c'est
ça ce sont des mesures bloquante tester
c'est juste constater et c c'est le
quart no man qui mesurent la temps la
température oui ça ne fait pas baisser
la fièvre
alors qu'arrive et les mesures bloquante
un système de contrôle renforcé sera
mise en place dès demain pour ceux qui
arrivent du brésil d'argentine dû chili
d'afrique du sud et d'inde aujourd'hui
la menace elle vient surtout de
l'extérieur ce sont les variants du
cornât virus qui préoccupe avant tout
oui oui parce que
ils font beaucoup de dégâts très
rapidement vous avez vu qu aujourd'hui
le variant anglais est déjà à plus de
80% présents sur le territoire
le variant sud africain est majoritaire
dans un département comme la moselle
donc c'est un vrai risque est là encore
il a fallu batailler pour la fermeture
des lignes de transport entre ces pays
hautement risqués et notre pays à
l'autre de la santé défendre le vaccin
astrazeneca sérum pointé du doigt ces
dernières semaines après de rares cas de
caillots sanguins est ce que la raison
les vignerons de faire de la pédagogie
sur ce vaccin
alors oui il a raison sur et sur les
effets secondaires
après il ya le problème des délais chic
a cité en particulier sur sur lorient et
ça c'est un vrai souci
quelques que l'on a beaucoup d'avoir
débriefer avec nous de cette conférence
de presse thierry amouroux porte parole
du syndicat national des professionnels
infirmiers